foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show we're dead as dumb Cassius
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Christina
Ellis Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
thank you for joining us America we are
so glad you are here the phone number is
888-825-5225 that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five so a little
inside baseball and stating the obvious
for those of you watching YouTube we're
trying a new rig today that uh is going
to be our new thing with microphones and
actual in-ears we've worn the sports
headsets for I have worn the sports
headsets for 20 plus years and the
reason was we used to do a lot of
remotes and things out and the uh the
microphones and the uh
the earphones and so forth uh were
better for that and uh I I tend to
wander all over the place and flap my
hands while I'm talking and it kept me
on mic back in the day but I started on
traditional radio mics back in the day
of course and did the first decade on
microphones much like her in front of me
again right now and are in front of
Christina again so the team has uh said
every 20 years you ought to change
something you know so we changed
something so if you're tuning in today
you're getting a full bald head with no
microphone to cover it up so I had to
really work on my hair for the day make
sure it's all dialed in and Christina's
hair is not messed up for a change right
thank God so all of our guests except me
are going to have a much better hair day
and it's hard to improve my hair day
it's just about as good as it gets and
it's that way all the time so if you're
tuning in on YouTube or you're watching
a podcast in some form that has the
video with it uh yes we know there's a
change thank you we're just saying it
out loud triple eight eight two five
five two two 5 Michael is with us in
Madison Wisconsin hey Michael welcome to
the Ramsey Show
oh thanks for having me on sure what's
up
um so I'm wondering
I read your book Total Money Makeover
and I'm reading baby says millionaires
but my question is
for my business I'm debt free and I
decided to buy a building
using your method of paying cash for it
and now I have all my debts gone except
my house good
and I'm wondering when does the math
play in
like if I'm expanding my business to
continue doing that debt free or pay
down the mortgage
oh you're saying whether you use some
extra cash you've got from this point
forward to pay off your house or whether
you expand your business
right yeah uh Bose I'm going to take a
good amount home and get my house paid
off as soon as I can reasonably and I'm
going to keep expanding my business uh
but am I going to pay nothing on the
house so that I can expand the business
more no I'm not I want to get the house
mortgage gone too because here's what
happens Michael uh how many people have
you got on your team in your business
six okay
I was at 10 or 15 people uh when I got
my net worth back to one million dollars
and I was 100 debt free from that day
forward my business
decisions were affected positively
because I was not afraid
yeah
and I have at that point yeah you you
feel that way around the business but
you're going to get one more click on
the notch not not 10 clicks but you're
gonna get one or two clicks more when
you pay off the house when you go now
we're just in a Monopoly game
right and every time we pass go we
clicked 200 oh and we hit free parking
here we go and it changes it changes the
way you look at your business and you'll
never I take a lot of risks with our
business but all with cash and so if it
goes sideways and I lose my butt on
something uh it's my butt
not the bank's butt
sure enough yeah and it changes it
you're gonna love it you're gonna love
it so yeah go ahead and work towards
getting your house paid off well what's
your hesitation so after you know buying
you know the business building in cash
and going on this journey what kind of
Switched and made you question
I wouldn't say I have hesitation I went
gazelle intents doing the building
um
but I have such a good interest rate
that's so low that
you know I I
that's my only hesitation my decision
has given me a double-digit return on
the building
um so no I have no hesitation so what
I'm proposing is is that you're going to
make a lot more on your business because
you're going to make different decisions
than you're making on that mortgage
okay so you've kind of got it envisioned
I'm borrowing money at three percent so
I'm making money by reinvesting it
somewhere else I'm saying your decision
making Paradigm will change it enough to
offset that interest rate uh because
free people make different decisions
than slaves
correct and that's what it comes down to
and so I I just I've watched businesses
and entree leadership do this for
decades now and when they get everything
paid off building house everything they
have zero debt
their need to take on a marginal
customer who's high maintenance
and just to take on the cash flow it's
like yeah
you're a high maintenance customer I
don't make much money on you I'm going
to go ahead and fire you as a customer
and oh by the way that frees up
resources and bandwidths to take on good
customers that are a lot more fun and
you make more money on them and so but
you don't drop that marginal customer if
you've got a mortgage hanging over your
head you hang on because we got we need
the cash flow you know and that kind of
stuff and that that's the way it works
in your brain when you're running a
business so
um
what 10 which path 10 years from today
15 years from today do you think will
take you to the best place and uh I'm
sitting there 10 or 15 years the other
side of you
having done the exact same thing you're
doing and
um I can promise you the one I'm giving
you will be a place that you'll be happy
you went to and there's no
economic situation or political party
and power that will make you sad that
you're debt free
absolutely yeah your your story is
literal walking proof of this you you
didn't go the fast way it's similar to a
lot of our money principles where yes
there's other ways that people tout is
getting rich quicker but sometimes the
slow and steady path with Biblical
principles is the way that will get you
further in the long run yeah it always
does it just it's never the microwave
it's always a crock pot and uh and I'm
now starting after 30 years of doing
this to really see and a lot of our
customers and a lot of our friends and
in our families lives the
um what we didn't realize was going to
be positive I mean Matt first thing is
you go oh I'm saving all that interest
oh I can't get foreclosed on oh and then
you start to realize I make different
decisions I my tolerance for uh crazy
customers is much lower which also makes
you more profitable by the way it makes
your life better if you're running a
business my tolerance for team members
that misbehave is much lower I have
Grace for them but my need financially
to put up with someone because they're
bringing money into this building is
zero
zero so it causes me to not make
decisions based on anything except
principle
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we were drawn to Christian Healthcare
Ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
Health Care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the Better Business Bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
foreign
[Music]
Merry Christmas America in case you
couldn't tell the debt-free screams are
kind of a big deal around here because
the folks who stand on that stage are
heroes they choose to live like no one
else and now they get to live and give
like no one else and that's why we have
started the giving I started giving
every one of them doing their debt free
Scream the live and give box it's the
tool kit
that'll help you walk out the whole baby
steps Journey so it's The Total Money
Makeover book
the baby steps millionaires book
and an entire year of Financial Peace
University all of this is just 99 and
that's over 200 worth of items so it's a
great deal if you're brand new the baby
steps this takes you all the way through
the baby steps and gives you every
detail putting you into Financial Peace
University that you should have been
living with all along so if you're debt
free and you're on your way to being a
baby steps millionaire this is how you
can give like no one else and pass on
the freedom the live and give box go to
ramsesolutions.com
slash box
ramseysolutions.com slash box Christina
Ellis Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
Ron is with us in New York City hi Ron
welcome to the Ramsay show
thank you big fan big YouTube fan well
thank you how can we help sir
yeah so I have roughly about uh 17 000
in student loans
um in around 58 000 in my savings
account and I just wanted to find out it
was a good idea to kind of pay down the
loan completely um but it would deplete
my thing is about one-third so you know
they say cash is King especially post
covers I'm kind of just fearful of like
uh not having too much money in my
savings but I also want to know your
opinion about paying that down
pay off your loans
I love that this is an easy conversation
because you got the savings you got the
money to do it I mean we we want people
through the baby steps thousand dollar
starter emergency fund then paying off
the debt and you got it which is very
exciting Ronnie you're having a hard
time getting a date so you want to date
Sally May
no no
[Laughter]
I do have like aspirations of buying a
home and this is like ask the most money
that I've had would you borrow it would
you borrow a student loan to buy a home
no okay if you use money that it was in
your account that is equal to your
student loan you realize it's the same
thing
yeah yeah
so I've got aspirations of you buying a
home too but I don't want you to do that
with Sally May having live in the extra
bedroom since y'all aren't going to date
she shouldn't live in the house
yeah
interest rate is pretty favorable I
think it's like a 3.4 percent
if you could borrow 20 million dollars
or 3.4 percent would you
I think I would yeah yeah I think you'd
be broke in a short period of time after
that
now I I if I were you you called and
asked us what we think you should do
Christina's right on it I would pay off
your loans as soon as you possibly can
quick as you can get rid of them get rid
of them now and uh that's your shortest
distance the shortest distance between
where you are and being a baby steps a
millionaire or being a millionaire is to
get rid of your debt and open up your
most powerful wealth building tool which
is your income yeah and I just think
it's such a mindset shift because I
think there's a lot of fear in the world
and there's a lot of misperceptions and
people feel like they need to hold on to
their cash but if you have debt that's
not safe yeah what's interesting is is
that you're afraid of the wrong thing
you know you're you're you should be
more afraid of having that debt if it's
a fearful time out there and it is a
fearful time out there for a lot of
people but you should be more afraid of
being in debt at times that are crazy
like this than you should be uh 17 000
Less in your 58 000 bank account exactly
and going in you're not even going to
know the difference
yep and going into purchasing a home
buying a home
a free outside of that which is going to
give you so much more security you don't
want to have a mortgage payment and
addition to having student loans that
you're still dragging around absolutely
Regina is in Las Vegas Nevada hi Regina
how are you
I gave her Christina happy holidays to
both of you you too how can we help
um I have a question and it's going to
be a Dave what would you do in my shoes
um I have a debt of 6 800 total in
following the baby steps working
desperately hard three jobs I have a
specific debt that is owed to my
ex-husband of Seventeen hundred dollars
he has threatened to take me back to
court and to incur fees on this debt I
do owe him the money I fell behind
because I owed him 150 a month and
unfortunately I was down with covid so
he is now threading threatening to take
me back to court and then they actually
add on fees and interest
I want to kind of jump off the baby
steps pay him from a loan at a 401k
and get rid of him and get him off the
Ledger for the Year what's your thoughts
so you're working three jobs how much
are you paying towards debt each month
with those three jobs
honestly I went from
um having six or seven decks to having
these last two one how much a month are
you paying on debt
um currently I'm paying about 500 I'm
trying to pay off my automobile that's
the only loan I have outstanding and him
and him yes but I want to just pay how
much money do you have in savings
zero I literally have you don't have the
one thousand dollar save that we told
you to have
unfortunately no day I I had an
emergency so I did have to use that okay
what do you own that you can sell
what are these three jobs that you're
doing
what type of work I don't I I do uh
different lift Port platforms like you
know Rideshare platforms and then I also
have a gay job
um and then I donate blood
what does the money do to him for child
support
no it's it's attorney fees that I owed
from the pandemic
they extended and extended and extended
and extended and unfortunately I
encourage oh that you owe me for the
pandemic
yes you had to pay your ex's attorney's
fees why
because I had a bad lawyer you and I
have already discussed this
unfortunately okay all right so this
money has been outstanding a while
I it's been I have been consistent until
the last six months I just I fell off
the bandwagon because again I was done
with coven
you weren't down with covet for six
months
yes sir
are you currently working
I am I have a
job that I work remote so I can stay
with a day job that I couldn't be with
the public and do the platforms or
donate blood
what's the uh what do you make
uh currently I make right around 57 I'm
sorry 47 I make 57 annually when I do
both the other jobs
so you're bringing in
four thousand dollars a month
roughly yeah
I also have child support out of that so
it does decrease that quite considerably
you have to pay him child support
yes sir how much
uh it's 350 a month
with this Seventeen hundred dollars what
do you feel like is the runway before
you're in trouble with it like how much
longer do you have to pay she's already
waited too late
correct
yeah
if you send him 500 a month for three
months he'll lay off because he can't
even get a court hearing before then
he's probably already had the paperwork
submitted he's that person
well you're the person that worries
about him being that person more than he
is that person
this guy's been ringing your bell a long
time
I'm tired I'm tired of it already
um that's why I want to get rid of him
yeah you're not going to get rid of him
he pay him 350 a month till your kid is
grown
so he's in your life and your kid is in
a great hope
absolutely yeah so duber's in the
picture you're just not getting rid of
him
tell her uh okay
um I I don't borrow on 401K so that's
why I'm hammering around the edges of
this trying to figure it out have you
tried uh anything like your credit union
to borrow the money
I I can't no and what I would do is just
stop spending on anything and start
sending him 500 a thousand dollars a
month and get rid of him and then catch
up on your other stuff if you get behind
on something so what but you're paying
your car nothing extra or paying it a
month late uh you're paying your light
bill a month late uh you're gonna crimp
down and just get him some money really
really fast and get him out of there but
I'm not going to tell you to go
borrowing your 401k it helps in the
short term but long term it's going to
cause you all kinds of problems
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is blinds.
calm
[Music]
Christina Ellis Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today open phone's a triple
eight eight two five five two two five
so for the email inbox you can always
send us an email if you want the email
address is ask ask at
ramsaysolutions.com Dave I recently read
an article that said you called The
Universities that are promoting online
gambling idiots I cannot agree more I
myself got addicted to gambling online
and it started in college it was
accessible but not as easily as it is
today I was a functional gambling addict
for almost 20 years it got so bad I
embezzled one million dollars from my
bank that I was working for to pay for
gambling and I served a three-year
prison sentence for my crime I am
recovering and doing well but obviously
no gambling thanks for speaking out this
addiction is serious and it's the real
thing and the last place it needs to be
is on college campuses oh
That's Heavy yeah so uh the uh Caesar
has invaded the college and uh the
colleges are selling some of them for
Big Money uh access to uh Sports Online
Gambling to uh alumni and students the
colleges themselves the colleges
themselves are are selling off their
their mailing lists oh basically and uh
serving up the people that they're
supposed to be serving the students
uh serving them up to Caesar no pun
intended actually Caesar yeah really
Caesars you know Caesar's Palace like
the little weird commercials with the
guy with the thing on his head and all
that crap that runs over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
and over like all prescription drugs run
over and over and over and over on the
sports shows I Wish by God they had more
than three commercials while I'm trying
to watch a football game
oh drive me nuts that is so toxic and so
crazy in an industry that already has so
much toxicity around student loans to
now be selling their list to gambling
companies big money too big money is
that they're making money from selling
the list or do they get commissions from
they they're making millions and
millions and millions of dollars it's uh
deloni and I were covered an article on
it here on the air the other day and
that's where I went off and called them
all idiots and morons and all those
names I'm not supposed to use that I do
on the air names that are illegal by the
FCC but not by my wife and so and the
FCC says I can call people those things
but when I get home Sharon says he
shouldn't talked like that on the radio
I'm not like you know it's only one way
to describe people like that moron's an
idiots that's the only thing I can come
up with so I mean who who trashes
the Next Generation and puts them
exposes them to the second fastest
growing Addiction in America today
fastest is online porn second is online
gambling
and you don't think we know these
numbers I mean we guess who we get to
coach and counsel for crisis Financial
counseling all across America every day
not just here on the air but with our 5
000 plus Ramsey coaches that have been
trained by us you know who walks in
their office most often addicts because
100 of addicts have financial trouble
eventually
and so guess who what we get to see we
get to see the actual ends of the
research that shows that oh yeah
actually pornography online is
destroying families at a rate that no
one talks about and is unbelievably
addictive and uh then right with it
right with it gambling and uh but it's
cool to bet on the football game now
because by God we have advertised until
we made it cool
and so um used to be you went to some
back alley bookie I wondered if you were
gonna get shot
but now you just log online and it's a
cool dude from Caesars and um and other
cool dudes are on the commercial with
him shouldn't have done that Peyton bad
call
I'm just calling you out there my
brother
think about what you're setting people
up for ah it's awful just awful I mean
these are the same people that are
allowing 18 year olds to take on
thousands of dollars in debt so it
doesn't completely surprise me hundreds
of thousands exactly we're not only
allowing encouraging Gary's in Houston
Texas hi Gary welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey hi Dave how you doing buddy better
than I deserve what's up hey hey yeah
well I'm uh yeah here in Houston I'm 72.
uh I don't actually have a retirement
other than Social Security I get about
2400 a month and I have thirty thousand
dollars in savings okay
so I have my house up for sale uh my
fiance lives about 150 miles from me and
uh she has a house that's paid for so
I'm selling mine
and uh we'll get married I'll move up
there okay
but here we are talking about how are we
going to develop money and of course if
I sold it I would be able to make about
200 000 on it okay yes sir
um if I she says why don't we just lease
it out because my lease my my payments
are only 882 and I could lease it out
for eighteen nineteen hundred dollars
and so I've just been struggling with
this so I thought I would touch base
with you and see what your thoughts on
this because um
um you know I'm trying to I'm 72 but I'm
how long has the house been on the
market
oh you know I got on in the market late
and and I think um the first of
September last of August and so it's set
for 72 days and I had two buyers that
fell through
and uh so now I lowered it my realtor
said well that's a little way from 320
to 305 and I still haven't gotten any
bites
okay well I mean
typically December would not be the
hottest month for people to be looking
at houses
we used to have a saying in the real
estate business if somebody wants to
look at a house in December by God show
it to them they need a house because
everybody else is out shopping for
Christmas and seeing Santa Claus and all
that stuff right so it's not a great
month for you to expect big results on a
price reduction uh I agree once you
approach Thanksgiving the market slows
down until after the first of the year
dramatically okay so let's back up a
second
um
no I want you to sell it I don't want
you to rent it your fiance is wrong here
let me give you let me give you two
major reasons why okay good one
eighteen hundred minus 800 when you're
renting a property is not one thousand
it sounds like it is but once the
property is empty uh a while you don't
get the full 1800. once the property is
not paid by the tenant and it takes four
months to get them evicted you don't get
the eighteen hundred once they decide to
change their Harley Oil in your living
room and you get to replace the carpet
because you can't find them because they
skipped town after that it's not
eighteen hundred so with the numbers
you're giving me you're about going to
break even
okay so I don't want to break even you
want some money number one number two
it's very very difficult to be a
landlord particularly a first-time
landlord from 150 miles away
correct can do a good job at it even if
you had a management company or a
trustworthy relative to watch over the
property it's still not going to be
washed over like you would watch over it
and you're a first timer you're going to
make mistakes on which tenants you put
in all of us do when we start that so I
would rather you take less money and
have all the money and none of the
hassle
you know that's that was my thing but I
was trying to tell her you know hey well
you know I I think we ought to sell it
and I do want to plug this in real quick
of course I've got a realtor that uh as
of January my contract ends and just out
of the blue okay well I'm a Christian I
believe in praying Okay so I've been
waiting and waiting and waiting you know
I just felt like I needed to wait and so
I've been patient and then all of a
sudden this Chinese lady knocks on my
door this morning yesterday
and she says hey how come you took your
house off the market I said well it's
around the end of the year and people
are really not looking and she said well
my sister doesn't speak English but
uh I know I said well I still have a
realtor you can check with him and she
said oh well if you didn't have a
realtor we would like to negotiate with
you and my sister doesn't speak English
but we would like we're interested in
buying your house
if you're a good Christian you also
believe in the devil
so you should be real careful here this
smells like a scam
[Music]
if they can walk through your realtor
and make you a valid offer that's fine
but if they need to dodge a realtor
because that way they can scam you that
means you need oh but she doesn't speak
English you can work through a realtor
if you don't speak English it's okay
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the Ramsey Show Christina
Ellis Ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Alex is with
us in Louisville Kentucky hi Alex
welcome to the Ramsay show
hey guys how's it going great what's up
so I got a a twenty thousand dollar debt
that is being garnished weekly from my
my paycheck ouch what's that from
that's from a side by side that I
purchased and then lost
wow okay
expensive side by side
yes yeah I've got all the bells and
whistles
okay and I'm curious I have about eighty
thousand dollars in equity in my home
and another six thousand dollars in
personal loan and credit card debt if I
should sell my house and pay off all my
debts and just rent until I can buy
again
or how much other debt other than the 20
say it again
it's 26 000 total in debt but 20 of it
is this garnishment
yes
what's your car worth
uh about five thousand are you married
no divorced
how much do you make a year
68 000
and you have no money I assume no you
would have already paid it you wouldn't
have called us right right yeah
okay and is that 68k is that just from
one job or do you by chance do other
things okay this is one job
well that's good news how much is your
house payment
uh my house payment's right at a
thousand one hundred okay
you have kids
yes four
okay
do you have custody of the kids
uh 50 50.
okay
um well the house is always the last
thing I sell
and then I the the question I always ask
myself and then all of us here on the
show ask ourselves is what would we do
if we woke up in your shoes
what will be our next step
um
so if I'm a divorcee a bachelor the
house is not that big a deal I do need a
decent place that I'm renting that I can
take the four kids to right when it's my
turn to keep it but um but home
ownership uh just a bachelor you know
loading up your stuff and moving out
it's not that big a deal emotionally how
long ago was the divorce
about six months ago yeah okay
um
if I'm in your shoes a fresh start does
sound pretty appealing
so yeah cleaning this thing off and uh
and then you know storing the rest of
that and restart my baby steps you're
debt free now you build your emergency
fund then you start saving to buy a
house because my guess is if you had 80
000 in the middle of the kitchen table
you wouldn't go buy a house right now
obviously you would pay these things off
you'd set your emergency fund in place
and then you start working towards the
house
um is there anything in particular about
this house that causes you want just
dying to keep it
well actually the house is almost
getting too small for the number of kids
it has
okay well I'm going
I'm cutting your shoes twenty six
thousand dollars when you make sixty
eight thousand dollars isn't that much
money we have people pay off a lot more
than that and not very long and you have
50 50 custodies so you you said that 68
000 is from one job and so you have
margin with your time when when the kids
are with their mom if I'm in your shoes
I'm going gazelle intense and just
knocking off that twenty six thousand
dollars now that's not to say you don't
sell the house just because you want to
sell the house but I think you can knock
this out yeah you could probably be done
in uh nine ten months
I mean 2 600 bucks a month
but that's just living on beans and rice
rice and beans and working two jobs you
know and you know just rolling up your
sleeves and saying I want this crap out
of my life I want all this negative
things in my rear view mirror now that
the divorce is in my rear view mirror
rather than looking at and then I've got
a clean future out ahead of man I'm a
homeowner with a bunch of equity so um
yeah I I
I think it's an awesome opportunity to
just clean it up if you go do what
Christina said that's a probably a
better plan than I was coming up with
I'm just trying to think it's probably
emotionally wrung out after the divorce
and but you don't have the you know the
constructions on your time so you got
the kids when you got the kids but when
you don't be at work right well they can
hear so much heaviness in his voice and
it's easy when you're in those really
heavy situations to only tunnel in in on
big switch sweeping actions so paying
off the house selling the house having
that 80 000 that feels good because it's
an immediate win but I think you can
fight through this and I think that you
need to hear that you can do this I
think I mean we see people on these
debt-free stages on the step-free stage
all the time who've paid off way more
money than that and have a really
difficult situation so I think right now
I just want to encourage you that you
can do this you can have a house with 80
000 in equity and have no debt if you're
willing to fight for it yeah one of the
things we always say around here we got
something tough in front of us
business-wise as we say what must be
true
so ask yourself what must be true for me
to have three thousand dollars a month
on this debt and be done in nine months
what must be true that means I'm working
two jobs three jobs and I'm living never
seeing the inside of a restaurant and
we're not buying a bunch of crap and
we're not going on vacation and we're
going to clean up the mess and the mess
that we made with the side by side
freaking Bentley side by side but um
that you end up 20 000 bucks upside down
on it I mean that's a story how do you I
mean I can imagine buying one for twenty
thousand but how do you end up losing
twenty thousand on one but I think he
already feels that shame like I can hear
that no I'm just saying that that's the
thing I want all that if I'm him I want
all that in my rear view mirror right
and so you can channel that if I'm him
to be angry not at myself but just at
cleaning up the mess exactly and how
good is it going to feel to know that
you fought through it that you took
ownership of it and that you fought to
pay off that debt when you get to the
other side of that you're gonna have
such a feeling of just relief and pride
in the fact that yeah you made a mistake
but you know what you fought to overcome
that mistake
Caleb is in Fort Myers Florida hi Caleb
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey how's it going Dave better than we
deserve what's up
so I am currently 18 and I have two
credit cards
um however I've had I set them up on uh
automatic payments so they don't hold
any value at the end of the month so I'm
I'm debt free
however I have been saving up some money
and I have about seventy thousand
dollars saved and I was wondering should
I invest that money or should I go ahead
and look towards a place to like Buy in
a condo or apartment did you say seventy
thousand dollars
yes at 18.
yes way to go Kayla whoa that's
impressive how'd you do that what do you
make
um I mean work through high school and
you say save my money I'm not really a
huge spender and I can tell no no you
don't spend on anything
what do you do for a living
um well that's the thing is I didn't go
to not going to college and I started a
family business with my dad a couple
years ago and just working with that
right now
and that's you're making Obviously good
money
um not really I mean
only taking about like 45 000 a year out
of
out of that are you still living at home
by your parents
I am okay all right first thing I'll
tell you to do is go get an apartment
before I talk about buying a house okay
or go get just go get your place to live
and establish yourself as an adult
somewhere you don't have to do it today
but but that's an interim step before
you talk about buying a house way to go
on the 70 000. so the answer to your
question is I always ask myself what
does the data say what are the actual
facts say to become say a millionaire
okay we've studied 10 000 millionaires
the number of them that said I
um became wealthy because I have credit
cards that I pay off every month and
never carry a balance the answer that of
the people that became wealthy because
of that action is precisely zero none of
them did now some of them do what you're
talking about and most of them don't if
you're going to pay it off every single
month just use a debit card
and then you're not carrying a
rattlesnake in your pocket hoping it
doesn't bite you
because if you keep playing with snakes
eventually they're going to bite you I
mean you've made it like one whole year
or something of your adult life doing
this so
um you're asking for trouble I wouldn't
ask for trouble I would just get debit
cards use those and continue to pile up
cash and buy a house someday when you're
ready you're doing really good but I
wouldn't play with snakes this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three-minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramseysolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show we're dead as dumb
Cassius King in the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice
I'm Dave Ramsey your host we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
Christina Ellis Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five David is with us
in Dallas to start off this hour hi
David welcome to the Ramsay show
yes thank you sir for having me sure
what's up
yeah so just quick context my wife and I
when we were engaged did FPU that was
six years ago we are now five thousand
dollars away from being debt free aside
from our mortgage way to go I'm just
five thousand yeah thank you just five
thousand left of our uh of my student
loans
um here's here's the thing we're pastors
here in Texas we are moving to Oklahoma
to be pastors of a church there and
what's awesome is part of the deal is we
have a parsonage so we will not have a
mortgage payment there
um and so my my Ultimate Dream is that
we are financially independent from the
church I love the church I would love to
one day not even have to take a paycheck
from the church and so what I'm seeing
is our expenses are staying the same our
income's actually going up a little bit
uh with this move and I would like to
turn my house in Texas uh into an Airbnb
property and hopefully even make income
to take one step closer to being
financially independent from the church
and so my question really is is that a
smart move or should I just sell my home
here in Texas profits I don't know the
way the market is right now I can maybe
profit 60 70k something along those
lines from what I've seen and so I'm
just asking you what may be the better
or best option is
um I love your goal
and I don't dislike your plan overall I
would I would sell the house and move
the money to Oklahoma pile up some more
cash and pay cash for your first rental
in your own backyard
airbnbs uh have
two problems that all the people that
talk about how much money they make with
them don't bring up or they have three
problems that people don't bring up
problem number one there's a ton of
hassle a lot of details a lot of work
involved in getting the people in
getting them out getting them cleaned
all that kind of stuff like uh probably
25x a normal a normal rental because
you'll have multiple renters in a single
month right
and so you've got you've got maid
service you've got a higher level of
Maintenance you've got a lot of work
involved in managing and messing with
them okay so a lot of hassle uh can I
speak go ahead so sorry interrupt can I
just speak to that I do have family here
in Texas that would be managing the
property and so I kind of have a little
bit of a built-in system which is a bad
idea
you're going to take you're taking
advantage of your family okay I'm
telling you Airbnb the hassle factor is
very high there's great money but the
hassle factor is very high so if you
want to do an Airbnb it needs to be in
your backyard problem number one with
airbnb's problem number two of airbnbs
is you have a lot of extra maintenance
people tear the crap out of your
property
nobody talks about that that's the Dirty
Little Secret of airbnbs you're
constantly buying carpet you're
constantly buying paint and drywall
repair uh because they do not take it I
don't care how big a deposit you get or
how much screening you do it's not their
house and so you're going to have a high
level of repairs and maintenance which
is part of that hassle Factor the third
thing that nobody's talking about is
several areas uh are now passing zoning
prohibiting it right right and uh so if
you set your whole model up only on
Airbnb that you could have the rug
jerked out from under you if the only
way the deal works is Airbnb don't do
the deal because it might not be
available to you now if you want to run
the hassle for the extra money and run
the maintenance for the extra money
you'll make more money but it's a lot of
work so I would move the money to
Oklahoma whether you're going to do a
straight rental or whether you're going
to do an Airbnb because it's in your
backyard and you're going to lay your
hands on it and you are a man who
controls your desk Destiny you don't ask
your first cousin to do it
yeah that's that's what I would do if I
were in your shoes but I like your
overall idea but let's just pay cash for
a rental and go that way Christina yeah
I've talked to a lot of Airbnb owners
and it kind of does feel like a
part-time job for a lot of them and and
you get six of them it's a full-time job
um
yeah and I agree that having your family
do that would kind of be taking
advantage of them especially if you're
not paying them if they don't get a cut
of that and if you start paying them
then the need for doing an Airbnb goes
away yeah exactly and there's just a lot
of of mental aspects of like I mean
there's a review system on there so even
with the maintenance even with keeping
your Airbnb up you want to make sure
that it's Top Notch because you want
those five star reviews if not you're
gonna have a tougher time booking people
and the list goes on and on it can
definitely be more of a headache and I
think your heart is with the church you
ultimately want to pour your heart into
the church that's why you want Financial
Independence so that you can love on
people better and if you're stressed out
by this basic other part-time job that's
not going to be the best use of your
energy yeah I think it's a good move I
love your move to Oklahoma and you're
making more money just take your the
fact that you don't have a house payment
anymore pilot on top of that 60k go pay
cash for your first house then pile all
that rent up and or Airbnb money up
whatever it is and go pay a cash go pay
cash for the second house and then go
pay cash for the third house and you end
up with five or ten properties you'll
have enough income coming in that you
are independent and then you can decide
um how you're going to serve the church
and and what the financial arrangement
of that is you that gives you the option
of that and it does put you in a
completely different position
um in the church world for sure and I
love your heart and where you're talking
about going with it yeah and that's a
super exciting move congratulations with
all of that a new job new promotion and
not having to pay rent or a mortgage
that's outstanding so I think you're
going to be able to pile this cash up
quick
yeah it's going to put you in a really
really good position so I've got a good
friend that is a pastor and he started
at that age buying properties and he's
done exactly what he's talking about
doing he's become he's become he's got a
lot of real estate become wealthy and he
didn't steal the money from the church
and he didn't get overpaid by the church
he just managed his money well for
decades and has a bunch of paid for Real
Estate now and he's good at real estate
he's a pastor but he's good at real
estate and so uh you know he's managed
the properties well and he's you know he
it's like his little side job so to
speak his hobby he loves fooling with it
he loves messing with real estate like I
do and he's just done very very well so
he's many many years ahead of you uh
David and
um he has done what you're right you
know he's put himself in a position that
he's independent from the church and so
he's publishing deals all that kind of
stuff he just he doesn't have to uh be
unquote owned by the local congregation
unquote and I it might even change your
preaching a little you never know uh
could well some people it would
ah there you go this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
America we're so glad you're with us
this is the Ramsay Show Christina Ellis
Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself whyblinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings with free samples free
shipping and new promos they run every
month you'll save even more use the
promo code Ramsay to get the best
possible deal today's question comes
from Ashland in Texas I received a
student loan refund from the Relief act
pending the student loan discharge now
that the court has blocked the discharge
of loans should I send the refund back
to my lender for the loan
hmm Dave you know I love talking about
this it kind of feels like right now
it's like the wild west out there with
this whole student loan forgiveness act
I'm hearing things things about people
just getting these refund checks that
didn't even ask for refunds they're just
sending the money back even though they
didn't request it so and then some
people are asking for the money back so
for those of you who don't know people
who paid on their student loans during
covid since student loans were paused
they're eligible to ask for a refund on
that money in hopes that student loan
forgiveness will go through but here's
the thing it's not gone through yet and
I think a lot of people are seeing these
refund checks and assuming that that's
their money now almost as if forgiveness
has happened and that all is okay but I
really want people to stop for a minute
and realize that that money until and
unless forgiveness goes through that's
debt they're just they're just putting
you back in debt with those refund
checks so if you it it's one more time
that the government used the wrong word
it's not a refund
it's not a refund
uh they just loaned you ten thousand
dollars more
yeah you had thirty thousand dollars in
debt
you would and now you have forty
thousand dollars in debt
well they sent money back that you paid
during covet I know and it's and you're
back in debt you're back in debt or
you're in debt more one of the two
whichever one it was but yeah so they
just put you back into debt
as of this moment in time
if they sent you ten thousand dollars
you now have a ten thousand dollar debt
it's not a refund
it was a loan they loaned your money
again right and and student loan
forgiveness it has not passed at this
point so it is so important that if you
got money back if you got that refund
check do not spend that money
don't spend that money
now if you want to send it back I mean
that's up to you again this is kind of
all new territory this is a very strange
situation for us what's the downside of
sending it back
the downside of sending it back nothing
right and if they do forgiveness they're
going to send it back to you again there
you go if they don't do forgiveness
you're not screwed and in debt again
so send it back
well in the danger of keeping it is
you're in debt you're in debt until they
pass all this crap and they get it
through you might be 96 years old when
they get this stuff through
and there's that Temptation that's
assuming you're 16 now by the way
there's that Temptation then to spend
that money oh no no yeah yeah yeah it's
not a Temptation it's a likelihood
so yeah send it back
you ever get one of those things in the
mail from the rip-off finance companies
or you know like companies like
beneficial which isn't
you know you ever get those checks in
the mail it's like just deposit this
check yeah you ever seen those it looks
like a check when you flip it over it's
a 34 interest loan
and you can just deposit this thousand
dollars they sent you a check like it
was for a thousand dollars what was it
it was a loan at 34 from beneficial
who's not you know that's what it was
right that's what they're doing but
they're here to help you Dave yeah
they're they're here to help we're we're
from the government and we're here to
help those are words that should chill
the very spine in your soul oh my gosh
uh so yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah send it
back now uh let's see we got a February
supreme court date to rule on what the
lower court has already said that Biden
the student loan forgiveness program is
not valid okay Supreme Court has now
been asked to rule aren't they say
they're going to rule on it in February
um
and after they rule on it you know
what's going to happen
you have a republican majority in the
house and you have somewhat of a tie or
whatever the flip we want to call it in
the Senate and so
it's going to get all stirred up and
tied up in Congress because Congress the
Republicans are going to try to pass a
bill to keep Biden from doing this
and so it's going to get Frozen again
oh and then it's going to get Frozen up
no no no you're going to be 96. you'll
be 96 years old In This Crowd I'm not
kidding you
when we were a kid we used to say my you
know just rednecked language it's like
well actually you're going to take an
act of Congress
what we were saying was it didn't likely
to happen
um
well this takes an act of Congress
probably and it's not likely to happen
so you do what you want to do but you
asked us Ashland which is a dangerous
thing because we are experts in our
opinion I would send it back
well and here's the thing by sending it
back by not counting on this forgiveness
now you don't have debt right what do
you have to lose you might lose they
might come out and go well the people
that all sent it back we're not going to
forgive theirs they might do that you
might you might lose the money but let's
see you already
owed the money
like you borrowed it
so oh well
uh Joe who's a welder and Susie who's a
waitress the taxpayers are bearing the
burden of this by the way and Joe who's
a welder and Susie who's a waitress who
didn't go to school and doesn't have any
student loan debt get to pay your debt
and you didn't they don't have to pay
yours because you had to pay your own
debt oh darn
I morally hate that you paid your own
debt and Joe the welder and Susie the
waitress didn't have to pay your debt
for you I really hate that for you
um that's just Dave you're not very
empathetic with the Gen Z generation
they they need you to meet them where
they are I don't need to meet them where
they are I need I need you to I need you
to grasp what's going on right here it's
a moral obligation when you sign your
name to pay something that you go pay it
and when you don't pay it and the
taxpayer has to pay it that's unfair to
the taxpayer so give the refund back for
that reason and for the fact that these
dupers have put you back into debt again
and you're twirling on the end of their
string again
stop it yeah stop it you don't have to
you don't have to sit there and wait and
be anxious and be part of this whole
chaos right now you can watch the news
with uh or not watch the news and you'll
still be okay yeah see the only reason I
get any news is because James our
producer brings me news
because otherwise I don't put that crap
in my brain you're probably a happier
person oh I'm so much happier I got
consuming that stuff during covet and I
stayed so pissed off the whole time just
because I was watching all these people
being pissed off and it just pisses you
off and you just spent all your time
being met why do I need this crap in my
brain so I scan Fox for about a minute
and a half in the morning just their
front page of their website and just see
what's going on so I kind of have a few
of the stories out there floating around
and then you guys bring me stuff in here
to do and other than that I'm not on
freaking Facebook and I'm sure not
reading Twitter
um and I'm for sure not a Tic Tac I mean
Tick Tock
um so you know I mean it's just my brain
is I'm such a nicer person now that I
did that y'all should have found me
before you think I'm mean now you should
have seen me back then so seriously it's
you got to watch your inputs uh and you
don't have to watch the news if you
don't have any student loan debt well
and with this stuff people are getting
pretty hot about it like on both sides
of what you just said I'm like Dave
you're stirring the pot like you're
gonna get something oh human people are
gonna react to me oh such a new thing
for you yeah I'm stirring up a Ruckus
here's the thing I've been doing it for
30 years and I've been helping you folk
because I love you and I want you to win
and I'm going to tell you the truth and
one of the things that causes you to win
is a high level of Integrity personal
Integrity pay the taxes that you owe I
hate taxes but I pay every single penny
I owe I do not cheat I do not lie on my
tax return not because the IRS is
wonderful not because Congress doesn't
suck neither one of those are true
Congress does suck and the IRS is not
wonderful that has nothing to do with my
integrity
whether I pay my taxes says my integrity
and if you want to win you got to have
integrity folks it's a long-term play
and so I love you enough to tell you the
truth have integrity it's one of the
things that causes people to win with
life and money it's an amazing thing so
if you know if that messes up your Tic
Tac well have at it this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Ellis Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
Dave is in Denver hi Dave welcome to the
Ramsay show
hello sir how are you better than I
deserve what's up
okay so uh I'm thinking about making a
career change as I just want to know if
it's something wise
um a little background we're in baby
step seven
and we have some cash stored up in our
savings and we got you know some
retirement saved as well
um I'm thinking you have made me a
transition
um entity and mortgage loan officer
currently I'm a police officer making
about 110
000 a year before overtime but looking
to make this career change
okay
why would you do that right now
um you know it's not I I love my agency
exhaust in a lot of ways but I love my
kids more and I'm looking you know with
the swing and graveyard shifts that I'm
doing I'm often gone
and I'm looking to kind of have more
time making to soccer games and things
like that
um
is the 110. looking back with my kids
yeah is the 110 is it a combination of a
lot of overtime or is it is that yeah no
I so I I'm actually a sergeant so that's
my base and then I get a little timing
on that the other thing too is I also uh
I did 10 years in the Army and so I get
some VA benefits
um about 3 700 a month
so that could supplement Us in the first
year or two
while I make the transition it's if that
was the case
okay I I think if you want to change
careers I'm perfectly fine with that
um one of the things you have to really
study is the timing of your career
change
um
there we've had more mortgage companies
close up shop completely go broke and
shut down
in the last six months that in any time
the last decade
uh and most mortgage companies have
reduced their staff by anywhere from 50
to 70 percent
and the reason is is that with interest
rates being six percent uh it refinances
have all but stopped
and most of the business that the
mortgage comp most the money the
mortgage companies were making was not
off of new sales it was off of
refinances
and so they would take a three percent
loan or three percent mortgage rate
refinance of four percent and it would
come out good uh so uh they're they're
laying off mortgage Underwriters they're
laying off people uh and or closing
their doors at a unbelievable rate at
this particular moment because the
mortgage business has just stopped uh
with the increase in rates until we see
now they are still seeing some loans go
through and the loans that are going
through are new house purchases are the
purchase of new of new properties but
refinance business is all but dried up
and it's um it was it was a large
percentage of their uh annual income at
the typical mortgage company so back in
the day three years ago two years ago
you could have made a couple hundred a
year
as a a mortgage originator
pretty easy
and you could learn the business and
gone in and yeah I would have told you
to go do that but right now I wouldn't
go into that to that right now not today
what's making you want to pick
that industry
because that is quite different from
please
yeah no there's a another thing about I
really want to get into the marketplace
um it really excites me um I'm a big fan
of the month in the merchant
and uh I just want to break into
Marketplace The Firm that they they said
they would take me on it's a small firm
but they do a lot of deals now I say
that but they've been averaging
um per broker One Mortgage a month over
the past few months
um because it's obviously like what
you're saying it's been really slow
yeah that's not a hundred ten thousand
dollars a year
no no not even close
but I didn't know if it'd be acceptable
due now to kind of learn the business I
would want to learn the business when
the business is booming not when it's
dying
okay let's let the market recover before
you enter that world or pick something
different I don't know what drove you to
that particular thing but I mean there's
other you could go into the uh you know
go get your securities license go work
for a smartvester pro uh and you know
get into the financial advising business
if you want to be in the marketplace and
you want to deal with numbers and you
want to work with that that's available
I mean and that's fine there's nothing
that business is not dying uh it's not
booming because the Market's slow and
and
um the stock market's slow and people
aren't lining up to invest but they are
still investing and they have they are
not doing refinances so
no I would not enter the mortgage
business today brand new from being a
police officer straight out of the box
it's not to say I think all mortgage all
mortgage companies are going to fail or
they're all awful or none of that I'm
not saying any of that they've had to
reduce staff because the reality is the
uh the marketplace with the refinances
has slowed down well and I know it's
exciting to have an offer in hand like
part of it is that he's got that offer
but I think it'd feel really great if
you got several offers in hand so let's
get them a copy of Ken Coleman's
proximity principle so he can start
figuring out you know who in his network
has different opportunities available
especially I know with police work a lot
of people right now that job is hard and
I think a lot of people unfortunately
are
kind of wanting to get out which makes
me sad my husband's a former police
officer retired from the Department
after 17 years and morale is really down
right now it's kind of unfortunately a
self-fulfilling prophecy when there was
all the hate against police officers it
really broke my heart because when my
husband went into police work he was so
excited about it like he had a full ride
to college super high ACT scores could
have done anything he wanted to do and
he chose to be a police officer because
he was just passionate about it he
wanted to make a difference in the world
but we went through that season of time
where they got a lot of hate and and it
really took a lot of the the spirit out
of a lot of the police officers who did
it for passion and were just really
excited to get in there so I've been
saying you know let's be careful what we
say towards police because the more you
hate on police you know they're going to
be one a mass Exodus of the best and
brightest ones and it's gonna it's gonna
be harder to recruit people who are
great at that field so in that I've seen
in the last couple years man these
police officers they feel beat up they
just feel you know heartbroken and I
know that there are some bad police
officers but a lot of them are amazing
and they did it out of passion and they
are there to serve and they are just so
excited to show up so I can I can sense
that you know in this last call you know
there may be that feeling of like I just
went out I'm I'm just worn out and it's
easy to grab that first job but
you know taking some time and going okay
this is not the month I would go into
the mortgage business
I would find a different month to do it
or I would find a different thing to go
into this month I don't mind you
changing careers you've done a great job
with your money you're in really good
shape so hang on we're going to set you
up with Ken Coleman's assessment which
will help you figure out some things you
could do now and help you line out that
way and we'll also send you from
paycheck to purpose the book Christina
was talking about and we'll help you
with that whole process but
um I personally I love the mortgage
business I've been grew up in the real
estate business I love everything about
that whole world but this is exactly the
wrong month
yeah exactly you may be leaving a
stressful career for another stress you
may be leaving a stressful career for no
money at all for a while and that's just
not this is not the time to do that open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five thank you for joining
us America we're so glad you're here I
don't think it's any secret that we love
Christmas time around here I do
there you go and hey it is a super busy
time of year and if you're still
shopping for the the folks on your list
you don't have to give a less meaningful
gift just because the clock is ticking
right now you can find something for
everyone on your list and get free
shipping on orders over 40 bucks you
have until December 8th to get free
shipping and have your gifts in time for
Christmas some of the favorite gifts
that go out this year the 2023 Ramsay
gold planner and I said the other day
the Rachel on there I thought they were
sold out they're not quite sold out but
very close and Rachel Cruz's new wallet
in red there you go there's your
Christmas thing and for the men new
Ramsay apparel t-shirts crewnecks
hoodies all with some of your favorite
Ramsay sayings on them and all your
friends family and co-workers questions
for humans conversation cards these are
a must check it all out
ramseysolutions.com
ramseysolutions.com and free shipping on
orders over 40 bucks check it out
ramsaysolutions.com
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you for joining us America
Christina Ellis Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Katie is in Colorado Springs hi Katie
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi good afternoon afternoon what's up
um
I guess basically to narrow my question
and try to keep it as simple
um as it can be we uh my husband and I
we run a business
um and we I just have tried to come up
with different ways on establishing
um a budget a cash flow process the
business that we run in is general
contracting and so with subcontractors
and different things it can be up in the
air it's not always consistent it's not
always the same
um things like that and and thank you
um
I I guess every direction every way that
I'm trying to establish a budget it just
always seems to be too complicated I
guess and I don't know if there's that's
really such a thing but I I just need
some I don't even know where to begin
anymore I just I've gone rounds in
circles it seems with trying to
create a cash flow system what kind of
shop is he what does he do
um so we do painting and flooring and
other general contract work in drywall
um in flooring painting decks interior
exterior and things like that
okay and he's providing he's not a
general contractor he's providing the
labor and doing the work
yes how many how many people how many
people on your team
uh we we run about five and then we have
um consistently about up to five four to
five and then we have other contractors
um Crews I guess that we we pull in as
needed when you look around your
community do you see someone who seems
to be running their business
in a very business-like button-up got
their crap together manner
yes and but not in I guess not in our
but there are other subconscious
drywall contractor flooring contractor
um a subcontractor that does Plumbing I
don't care
so if you can find someone or one or two
like that ask them what software they're
using
because there's a lot of good different
Builder softwares out there apps that
will help you manage this okay there's
two or three components to you getting
your arms around this and if you do not
get your arms around this you're going
to go broke
because your world your world is full of
broke people uh zombies that are walking
around still open that don't even know
they're not profitable
exactly and that's what I like from my
personality like I see that and I guess
my challenge has been in a way
um you know to try to come up with a way
that my will be you've got to get your
hands around it and and there's and
honestly there's software their software
that will really help you do that
there's like there uh I was looking
talking to a general contractor this
week that's using for residential that
and our our Commercial contractor is
building our buildings they're all using
project management software that tracks
every line item of the budget and keeps
everything in line and you're just
you're just all you're doing is
recording it as it goes along
and then it's spitting out reports for
you so the elements of what you're doing
are this
first there's the overall budget
and the overall budget is this month
this coming month what have I got coming
in
and what have I got going out
and write that down
and then give every dollar an assignment
and you can tell this month you might
not know about September right now but
you know the jobs he's on you know the
contractors you're taking a draw from
you know who what jobs are about to be
completed you're going to get your final
check on you know you know that some of
them wait 30 days to pay you you know
exactly where you stand you can get very
very close to the cash coming in this
month and the cash going out this month
and writing all of that down that is a
budget
okay and that you can do that without
software but I don't recommend it it's
just a pain in the butt the second layer
to this that is essential to staying
open and most subs don't do this and it
kills their profitability kills their
cash flow and increases their stress we
work with the construction businesses
all the time you can tell now the the
that the simple accounting term is
called job costing
and that simply means that you've got a
job for Joe and Susie over here and
you're putting a deck on their house you
have to run that job as if it's its own
Standalone business
what are they paying you for the deck
what are you paying for the wood the
nails the saw blades and the labor the
delivery the flat tire what are you
attributing to that deck of overhead and
then what's your profit on that deck so
your your income on the deck your every
element of cost goes to a certain code
and you've got deck01 is your code and
that's the first deck you did this year
and everything in that one everything
that's attributed to that job goes in
there and then you can tell if you
actually made a profit based on the bid
that you gave them it will change your
estimating later for future businesses
for future jobs that look similar
because you go on that last one we lost
our butt because wood goddess or we had
no idea we're going to go through 73
blades or whatever it is I mean you get
you get these things that come up and
you can but you can't tell that if
you're just throwing it against the wall
to see what sticks so you need some
software that helps you do your overall
budgeting and helps you do job job
costing which is effectively a profit
and loss statement on each and every job
such a good point Dave and I feel like
so many businesses struggle with this
it's what puts a lot of businesses out
of business and I'm curious you know
back in the day when you started this
business there wasn't all the different
software how software how did you start
with budgeting for business well we
started with you know
before computers were that big so I mean
it was literally I mean we're keeping it
by hand but the first thing I bought was
something like QuickBooks and it's just
a simple little uh back in the day you
would load a floppy disk okay and you'd
load that software on there and it would
help you run a basic profit and loss
statement a basic balance sheet it
wasn't that good but it was about the
best thing out there then then there was
another one we advertised for a while I
think it's still open and they do a good
job fresh books I believe it was called
and um but just look around in the
industry that you're in and figure out
peach tree is another one we got later
okay now we're with Oracle now we're
with netsuite with Oracle but that's a
super expensive for a larger business I
mean we're a 300 million dollar business
so it's a different situation than five
people on your team you know so you
don't you wouldn't want netsuite from
Oracle but if you're running a business
our size netsuite's incredible we just
converted to it what two years ago a
year and a half ago and the reporting
and stuff we're getting out of it it's
an amazing software where for the detail
and the you know we've got all these
different profit centers within Ramsey
that we're tracking and not unlike her
but with more zeros and more
complication so but the point is there's
there's some general software out there
and then there's in the construction
business there is some really good apps
and some really good uh project
management that has a p L's are
estimating and job costing built into it
and they're not super expensive you've
just got to go research figure out who
what people in your business are doing
find best practices and go Implement
them so you've made these changes
throughout the year throughout the years
and found better products how can a
business discern when it's time to
change oh we were breaking it I mean we
had old Peach Tree it would just it
would just collapse
it would fall in on itself it would
freeze up we'd have to reboot we'd have
to clean up stuff it we had so much
weight on it it couldn't carry it and it
was not made for as far as we took it
and then we had something after that
before we went to netsuite trying to
remember what the one that we pointed
out that did okay for it did okay for
like five years or six years so as the
as the size and the complexity of the
business increased
um and the software that we were using
the budgeting software the uh Financial
software did not increase in
sophistication and in capacity we would
collapse it it would fall in on itself
stupid computer freeze up you couldn't
get your reports out take six take six
and a half minutes to do something
should be half a second that kind of
thing and you quickly realize you got to
move out of it but but
you know right now at this moment the
technologies that are out there to help
you guys run your businesses are really
good but you've got to actually go do
the work and then you've got to put the
numbers into the software
every month every week
very important but it'll change your
it'll change your stress level in your
business considerably
that puts this hour of the Ramsey Show
in the Bucks
[Music]
foreign
all of our shows with the Ramsay Network
app on your smartphone it's the only
place to listen to the entire back
catalog of episodes download the Ramsay
Network app in your favorite app store
today
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage and Studios it's the
Ramsay show we're dead as dumb Cassius
King in the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people
build wealth
do work that they love
and create actual amazing relationships
Christina Allen's number one
best-selling author Ramsey personality
is my co-host today our phone number is
a free call and some say the advice is
worth exactly what you pay for it the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
JC is starting off this hour in San
Diego hi JC how are you
hi Dave Christina thank you for taking
my call sure what's up
should we pay off our mortgage yes or do
a long recast or continue our current
path
can you pay it off today
um yes the only thing is we would be
using all of our liquid assets in an
exception of maybe 10 15
000.
um
what's your household income
130. and how much your house payment
uh monthly mortgage is 31
once left is 152 000 at three and a
quarter interest
okay now by look what assets you don't
you're not talking about retirement
accounts you're just talking about money
you have in stocks bonds mutual funds
money markets that kind of stuff
correct okay
where did the savings come from so that
152 has it just been sitting there in
savings
so yeah it's just sitting there and
um you know we always like to be
comfortable of having enough
that's why it's just been sitting there
okay
okay what what is your do you have any
hesitations on paying off the mortgage
other than the Comfort aspect because in
my book it seems like you'd be more
comfortable having no no payments
um the main question is not having uh
liquid assets if we would want to buy
another property um
so you would borrow on your home to buy
another property
okay no
I'm asking that as a question would you
if your house was paid off would you
borrow against it to buy another
property
um I would not I would rather not do
that I want to pay it off completely no
no that wasn't what I asked stop stop
stop stop I said if your house was paid
off
would you borrow on your home
to buy an investment property
no Okay then if you use this money
to buy an investment property that
should have been used to pay off your
house it's exactly the same thing
it's as if you have borrowed on your
home to buy that property do you
understand
same exact decision
so
how old are you guys
uh going to be 15 and 49. okay here's
what I would do and you can do what you
want to do but you called and asked us
and then I'll tell you why I would do it
I would write a check by the end of the
week and do a Merry Christmas dance in
the freaking front yard that my house
was paid for okay
put Jingle Bells around your neck and go
out there and disco in the front yard
and drive the neighbors crazy right you
got to do something to celebrate so now
you're a hundred percent debt free house
and everything what's this house worth
750 okay how much is in your retirement
accounts
uh I would say around a hundred okay so
you're almost millionaires
right pretty close
okay
so you're very very close so soon you're
going to be baby steps millionaires the
reason now I would tell you to do that
is this when you have no payments in the
world you're going to breathe deeper
than you've breathed than you've been
able to take a breath into your lungs
for years
your your shoulders are going to be more
relaxed
and you're going to be able to sit down
with a budget and go I'm going to invest
five thousand dollars a month into an
investment to pay cash for future
properties and to give me a big old pile
of cash now if we invest five thousand
dollars a month for 10 months how much
is in the account
five times ten uh right
right no no no no no no no no no if you
start from zero
and you invest five thousand dollars a
month for ten months would you have
fifty thousand dollars
correct 10 months later would you have a
hundred thousand dollars
plus whatever the market has grown if
you're in good mutual funds during that
time
and ten months later so two and a half
years
from today let me tell you what happened
two and a half years ago today
we were not yet in covid
that's how fast two and a half years ago
goes okay in two and a half years you
are going to have
two hundred thousand dollars
approximately
you follow me that sounds great yeah but
just investing your house payment plus a
little bit more
and now you're an investor instead of uh
being fed on by the mortgage company now
you've got money working on you in your
direction if you will simply turn your
old mortgage payment Thirty One hundred
dollars plus 1900 more and you got that
into Investments you're going to put the
money back so fast and would you agree
with me that an extra fifty thousand
dollars in 10 months is going to be
pretty comfortable
yes without a house payment for sure
so we're not suggesting you live with
ten thousand dollars
or fifteen thousand dollars after paying
off your house for a long period of time
just for one month
then the next month it's plus five and
the next month is plus five and the next
month is plus five or whatever number
you decide to put in maybe you're going
to put in seven thousand because you
could easy without a house payment this
is the shortest proper way that people
build a wealth it is not popular uh with
people who want to build wealth quick
who want to get rich quick or quote
unquote easy but it is there's a lot of
peace with this
there's a lot of relaxed with this
and uh there's no risk with this oh and
by the way if two years from today you
hate being debt free you can go get you
another mortgage
you could couldn't you if I'm completely
wrong if I'm complete if I messed you
over with this advice that crazy butt
Dave Ramsey over there in Nashville I he
lost his dadgum mind I'm gonna go back
in debt you could go get your mortgage
so I dare you to try it I dare you to
try to
endure this level of financial peace I
don't know if you'll be able to stand it
it's going to be so awesome you may have
to go back into debt because you won't
be able to stand this much fun
love sarcasm well done you've done a
great job go pay off your house kiddo
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the holiday season our brains are
focused on buying presents decorating
homes and all the Christmas and New
Year's celebrations all of a sudden it's
January
and now some people feel like they've
gotten a financial hangover
it doesn't have to be that way
you can start the new year strong set
yourself up for a strong New Year join
us for our Building Wealth live event
here in Nashville on January the 12th
this one night event will help you kick
off 2023 feeling confident about your
finances even in this crazy economy join
me Rachel Cruz George Campbell Ken
Coleman and Dr John deloney as we walk
you through a simple but proven plan to
get back on track and Bill wealth yes it
is possible our Building Wealth events
have been huge
they've all been sold out all through
last year Nashville is coming up next
then we're headed to Indianapolis Austin
Salt Lake City Anaheim All Dates here in
the spring you can get tickets to any of
them past the start as low as 49 seats
are limited for this event so hurry
reserve your seat for our Building
Wealth live in Nashville today
ramseysolutions.com events
ramseysolutions.com events
100 percent of your credit score
is based on you interacting with debt
your FICO score
is not determined by you winning
financially
you could get your boss could walk in
today he's not going to she's not going
to and say you now make a million
dollars a year and your FICO score will
not change one point
the phone could ring and your
grandmother could say your Rich uncle
that you didn't know you had just died
and left you 10 million dollars and your
FICO score will not change one point
your FICO score is not a sign you are
winning with money
it's a sign you have played kissy face
with the bank
it is based on the debt that you have
the debt load the type of debt the
length of time you've had the debt the
ratio of the debt to your income
how you have paid the payments on your
debt it is an I love debt score
mathematically speaking the algorithm
says that you the way to have a 700
and 50 or 810 FICO score the only way to
have that is to really really love debt
you have to keep a lot of it and you
have to pay it
it will cost you hundreds of thousands
of dollars over a decade to build a FICO
score and keep a FICO score of 800
because it's the only way that FICO
score is calculated it is not an I'm
winning with money score it's an I love
to support the bank because they're so
awesome score
in other words it's dumber than a
freaking Rock
so here's what happens
when you quit borrowing money
and you've paid off all of your debt and
you don't have a single account open
your FICO score will disappear
within about a year
as a matter of fact they will treat you
like you have moved to Mars
like you have one eye in the center of
your head
your FICO score is now undeterminable
oh
you mean you can't determine that I
haven't borrowed money
I think it just means it's zero but it's
undeterminable
it's like going to the airport it's a
terminal I don't know I don't want to do
things that are terminal I'm going to do
things that bring me life if they say
you have terminal cancer that's not good
but we go to the airport and we call it
a terminal
undeterminable oh
sounds spooky the problem is so years
ago I quit borrowing money so I haven't
had a FICO score in like 30 years
um I'm not really here
I'm off the grid this is actually a
hologram I don't really exist because
according to you people I don't have a
FICO score so I'm a nobody but according
to my banker I'm a nobody with millions
of dollars in her bank
so and I still have a zero FICO score a
non-d undeterminable FICO score and
guess who just joined the club it's my
zero FICO score day
we sold our house in May took about five
and a half months and my FICO score is
zero that was your only debt yep and you
sold the house the mortgage is gone
you're a renter yep temporary
temporarily right now until you figure
out the housing market and what you're
going to do and uh from May to
basically end of November beginning of
December I have not had a single piece
of activity and zero accounts open of
any kind and no lates on there and no
bad debts on there obviously and uh
that's how long it took for your FICO
score to evaporate yes yes it's gone and
it's so funny the email was like
basically like oh we don't know what
happened this happens sometimes but we
can help you correct it yeah sometimes
horrible things happen to people and
we're here to help we're from FICO right
you're debt free wait what we can help
you get back in debt you haven't made
offerings to the great gods of FICO you
need to make offerings of Interest oh
great FICO you are the provider of all
good things we bring you offerings of
Interest so that we can buy anything we
want on credit later so you borrow money
why so that your FICO score's up score
goes up why so that you can borrow more
money so why because your FICO score
goes up so why so you can borrow more
money I had a dog that used to chase its
tail and he was crazy
hahaha
and this culture does it every day and
you're free I'm free man
like when when you're in that process of
waiting for it to go to we were talking
about this about a month ago you're
going are you sure it's going to go away
I'm like I'm not sure of anything with
FICO except that when you quit borrowing
money eventually they're gonna cause you
to say you don't exist yeah I was like
Dave how long how many more weeks how
many more months and he was just like
just stay the course Christina I think
it's gonna be a year because I at that
point so made so what is it seven eight
months yeah something like that for it
to go away right five seven months seven
months yeah for it to go away before and
and it went down before that yeah it had
a good like 100. uh
yeah like 700 right yeah all right and
and because you paid your mortgage on
time you paid everything on time and
then you got out of debt and then you
sold the house and so you went from 700.
so you had a fabulous by all standards
FICO score and it eroded it went down to
600s yeah going to the 500s I mean I
wasn't yeah I was just waiting for
myself you're asking me about it it's
scaring me it's getting low well I was
just waiting for emails I was waiting
for the email that said zero and so they
sent me an email saying that had been
updated and so I was like oh it's zero
and then I went and it was like 600 and
I was like oh being in the housing
market that's kind of yeah someday I
want to buy a house and I can't do that
with a 600 when's this thing going to go
to zero Dave and I'm like all the data
that we have all the you know all you
people out there that we work with all
the stuff you send us everything we keep
up with from you guys the research we
don't know because FICO doesn't publish
their algorithms right they don't tell
us what the thing is but just observing
people have done what you do it takes
six months to a year and yours took
seven months yep
follow the path and George had a zero
FICO score went and got a mortgage up
with manual underwriting with Churchill
Mortgage and so if you're going to go
get a mortgage with Churchill Mortgage
and you have a zero credit score an
undeterminable they won't write you a
mortgage and it's exactly the same rate
as if you had a seven or an 800 FICO
score
only they have to do stuff like do
manual underwriting so they have to
verify that you have money with your
bank you have to verify that you have a
job which is what they ought to free can
be doing anyway what are you doing
giving people a loan based on one number
I'm going to loan you eight hundred
thousand dollars for a house why because
you have one number that says FICO FICO
FICO oh that's so crazy it's crazy how
our system rewards debt and people who
are yeah it's more than rewards it I
mean by God it manipulates it and causes
it people just I mean because I I've
been doing this for 30 years the amount
of hate mail and hate crap I get to this
day telling people to not borrow money
and get rid of their stupid kissy face I
love debt score
is crazy I'm keeping my credit cards
open because Dave Ramsey doesn't know
he's talking about I mean he's only got
several hundred million dollars but he
doesn't know what he's talking about
dumber than a rock just dumber than a
freaking Rock way to go you joined the
club girl
this is the Ramsay show
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Ellis Ramsey personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us America
Merry Christmas to you
if you're out on your Christmas travels
and over the river and through the woods
to Grandmother's house we go and
Nashville is on the River or the woods
or whatever it is along the way you can
stop by we'd love to have you sit and
watch the show we do the show every day
on the glass from one to four with uh
free homemade cookies and coffee and
there's usually 50 to 200 folks in here
watching the show and during the
holidays sometimes even more and of
course the bookstore is open and the
museum and the picture opportunities and
all the stuff our lobby is all set up
for our fans and our visitors and our
listeners to come by so we hope you do
in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions one of
the items is the debt free stage with a
big debt free plaque right in the middle
of it and if you come here to do your
debt free scream of course that's where
you stand and thus is what's happening
with Jonathan and Lachey welcome guys
how are you pretty good thank you how
are you guys Merry Christmas guys where
do you guys live we live in Wilmington
North Carolina very cool all right tell
us how much debt have you paid off so we
paid off 53
804.95 and how long did this take 24
months good for you and your range of
income during that time we started
around about 35
000 and now we're at about 90 000 a year
okay 35 000 and now you're at ninety
thousand way to go what do you guys do
for a living
yeah we're
at tech company online
um and I work in the technical support
area cool and I work at the airport
working on the line as a like a martial
or crewman oh yeah cool okay help folks
Park where they're supposed to that's
right that's good without without
touching those wings yeah very good good
for you so what kind of debt was the 54
000
um all student loans all student loans
all Sally May was hanging out that's
right she gave her her eviction papers
baby and you are hitting the road road
oh woman get out of my house how long
you two been married uh it's been two
years so far oh yeah okay so right after
you get married you say listen I want to
be married to you Sally May's not
staying in our house exactly exactly so
what was the plan tell me how all this
happened
yeah
um so I grew up with my parents doing
Financial Peace and they did the um kids
version of it with us and then so you're
a financial piece baby yeah okay and
then um two months after getting married
we were like okay we have all these
dreams but we can't do it with
um that coming behind us and all so we
decided to hop on the train and do it
cool all right so uh Jonathan Lachey
says hey when I was a kid we did this
weird stuff and I want you to do this
weird stuff now like get out of debt
what'd you say actually my mom had been
to some of the classes as well oh you're
a financial piece baby too yeah I'd
heard about it I never really took it
super seriously but I'd heard of them
and uh basically we saw this opportunity
online to get your book for free the
Financial Peace book and we also found
that every dollar budgeting app I had
been using it and we just once we got
married we were like hey we want to
seriously do this we can start a family
right off on the right foot dive in
though yeah dive in exactly that's
awesome okay so the decisions made
you're both on board what did this
journey look like for you guys
man it was uh it was a lot of sacrifices
we definitely uh uh you know we live
like nobody else so that later we could
live and give like no one else and uh we
we did a lot of extra jobs and we lived
in literally a basement apartment for a
long time and uh no light yeah not much
and uh we I mean I did everything like
lawn care we sold a bunch of random
stuff we had uh just everything to go
all in and make it happen
um and we had sold off I think within
the first year and a half we were down
to
thirteen thousand five hundred and that
was when we figured out that Lachey was
pregnant with Kaden and so that was our
motivation to just say hey we're going
to get this done before this child is
born and so he'll be born into a
debt-free family I love it yeah that's a
milestone yeah absolutely very cool I
bet both parents are cheering young
because they're Financial Peace people
right yeah yeah you got big cheerleaders
All in the Family yeah and you're
bringing a grandbaby in so that makes
you hugely popular exactly yeah yeah
there's no question at that point you
are very likable kids you yeah pretty
much
so you guys are young your newlyweds a
lot of newlyweds are not thinking about
this at all they're just living their
best lives yoloing is that what they say
you know you're cool enough you know
that's what they say I know don't act
like you're old I've never watched the
young people I've never actually used
that word myself without joking
um but so a lot of people aren't doing
this did your friends think you were
weird
um my friends were like whoa I want to
be you yes
that's the way yeah set the standard set
the bar yeah well done so what would you
tell newlyweds who who were you know
kind of tempted to close their eyes put
their head in the sand and stay in debt
what would you tell them to get them
started on this journey
um I would say it's worth it not just
um for your financial sake but just for
your marriage overall I think it brings
up a lot of tough conversations that you
need to have and then at the end of The
Journey you feel like a really strong
team basically y'all y'all are a little
too sweet and Too Perfect all right tell
me the truth what was the big money
fight you had during the two years oh
man what was the one thing where you
like I just about killed him that's the
hard thing is trips like we want to go
travel and take big trips and it's been
so hard to just say like Hey we're gonna
do small stuff right now you know uh we
actually right after we got married well
we were going to get married and then
covet hit 2020 and we had to cancel our
honeymoon to Iceland and basically we
took all that money and put it towards
our debt and that was a hard that was a
hard move but we realized it was
something we needed to do to get started
so when you're going to Iceland
yeah that's a great trip I've heard I
haven't done that one but I've got
friends and family that have and they
just think it's incredible so you got to
do it yes you got to do it now so that's
cool so that I still didn't answer my
question because you still were like too
sweet you're like well we couldn't take
big trips I said when did you have a big
fight is what I asked I think it's um
based around trips so like I was around
I was based like raised to just doing um
like four-star hotels and like stuff
like that and then oh so he was trying
to cover for you he didn't want to throw
you under the bus and answering my
question so he's like um so I'm more
like we can do this and like spin this
and he's more so like no we can't so no
I think that's where we still we're
talking you're talking you're talking
Four Seasons I'm talking tent
pretty much yeah that's a reasonable
head
okay now I got it now we're coming clean
good hey you guys are sweet you're
powerful Your Heroes well done and then
you had uh the baby on the way and so
how old is your baby six months six
months old in name Caden little Kaden
all right way to go begging I love it
sitting over there with Janelle
Janelle's hating that so uh good stuff
so what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
I would say number one thing is just
seek to honor the Lord with your
finances and understand that it's bigger
than just yourself it's your family it's
your generation uh Generations after you
it's about making a change and also just
getting on the same page in your
marriage uh regarding your finances
because if you're in on different pages
you're just gonna butt heads it's like
one of the number one causes of divorce
I don't know if it's the biggest one but
finances are a huge deal and if you get
on the same page early on it's way
easier I'm sure
how old are you two I'm 24. and I'm 25.
why did you not wait on student loan
forgiveness
yeah yeah right it wasn't even a thing
when we started paying off debt so I
never really believed that was yeah
gonna be the thing um so now he said
we're gonna go do it forget waiting for
somebody else the government to take
care of that yeah okay 24 years old
you guys are amazing I'm so proud of you
very well done I know your mom and dad
are proud of both of you and uh you got
a great start and locadin's Mom and Dad
are heroes you set him up to win you
guys are ready to go man it's pretty
pretty amazing so let's get him in the
picture we got uh the live and give
bundle for y'all and that includes The
Total Money Makeover book to give away
to somebody that you've inspired the
baby steps millionaires book for you
that's your next chapter for sure go
ahead and be millionaires and uh live
and give like no one else and Financial
Peace University a one-year membership
so any of that you're welcome to keep or
welcome to give it it's our gift to you
and say we're proud of you and thanks
for coming to Nashville Jonathan and
Lachey and Kaden from Wilmington North
Carolina 54 000 paid off in 24 months
making 35 to 90. counted down let's hear
a debt free scream three two one we're
dead free
I love this gen Z generation man the
ones that are on it are more on it than
any gin I've seen so far 18 years old
with 75 000 saved 24 years old I'm not
waiting on the government you're kidding
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
our scripture of the Day psalm 34 4 I
sought the Lord and he answered me and
delivered me from all my fears
Cornelia Funke says children's author
says nothing is more terrifying than
fearlessness
you know what that's the truth right
that's a different level of swagger
right there nothing is more terrifying
than fearlessness when you're on the
other side of an equation from something
or someone that is fearless that is
terrifying I agree I agree it's powerful
good place to live too I like it it's a
good place to live fearless and part of
being Fearless is being debt-free part
of being Fearless is uh knowing who your
God is part of being Fearless is knowing
where you stand in your relationships
and part of being Fearless is known
where you stand in your career and where
your income comes from and when you get
those things that we talk about around
Ramsey all the time in place it does put
a different level of Courage into you
well and I think part of being Fearless
is not the absence of fear it's not that
you never have fears it's being willing
to do things in spite of the thing
things that scare you to death is being
willing to put yourself out there and to
go through the Journey even if you are
afraid it's not that the fears don't
exist it's that you're willing to plow
forward regardless of if you feel that
fear yeah but even then I mean when
stuff even like yeah comes at you then
you go yeah but what's the worst that
can happen and it does take because you
know I'm not going to lose my house I
don't have a mortgage
you know what's the worst thing Could
Happen what are you gonna do to me fire
me
get another job make more than I make
here and I don't have to put up with you
that'd be great fire away how big's a
severance let's have it you know it
changes everything it changes the
negotiation it changes the whole process
hey folks if you like this show help us
out uh we have found that um uh the
folks over at Spotify say we are in the
top one percent of all podcasts in the
world for having been shared we are
shared
so often that we're in the top one
percent of sharing or whatever you want
to call that I don't know what you call
it but anyway so thank you thank you for
doing that at Spotify thank you for
doing it Apple thank you for doing it
with YouTube thank you for telling your
friends and neighbors that we're on your
local talk radio station if you're in a
situation on one of those digital
platforms where you can leave a review
leave a five-star review or don't leave
one
but we do need your reviews and we do
need you to say you that you think the
show is awesome we don't need it but it
helps us spread the word and it takes
the uh the internet algorithm and kicks
it into gear and lets people know that
we're out here because all we're doing
is helping people this is all about Hope
and subscribe subscribe to the podcast
subscribe to the YouTube and tell people
to do that those numbers help as well
um
it helps us do everything we do here for
more and more and more people and uh
just spread the um spread this message
of hope it's a real message and it
really does work Chris is with us in New
York City hi Chris welcome to the Ramsey
Show
I do hi Christina how are you guys doing
great how can we help
doing well
um so my headline question and I can
give you the context is how do you
decide if it's worth in their life to
move based on the cost of living from a
personal finance perspective uh me
personally I'm kind of on the fence of
where I live now despite the fact I'm
doing well I like my job I mean I'm 25
have uh 150 000 annual income a hundred
thousand dollars saved away in
retirement funds uh you know only a
couple hundred dollars of that
and it's just an interesting time right
now because New York City in particular
like the rent rates have gone through
the road the taxation rates are you know
I don't even have to tell you how high
they are so how do you kind of in your
experience when has it when have you
seen it you worked it to to move if
someone's already you know if I like my
job I'm doing well but you know the cost
of living where I happen to be is just
so astronomically High versus like
almost anywhere else how great it is and
most of that cost living is real estate
in your case
compared to the rest of the country it's
bizarre you got to make a lot of money
you do make a lot of money
congratulations do you think you can
make a similar amount of money somewhere
else
yeah so that's I think the biggest
problem because it's like there's this
risk where
um I'd have to go out and search really
hard to find another job I haven't I
haven't yet to be honest I'm gonna have
skin gold but and usually like you don't
see it that high what do you do
uh I mean and you might not like this to
some extent that I have a stock market
researcher so on individual companies I
mean I don't dislike that at all
somebody somebody needs to research it
I'm not against the stock market I buy
mutual funds all the time and those
mutual funds depend on Research so I've
got a a friend that um is um
uh a young a young friend for a guy 62
he's in his 40s and uh he makes about
300 to 400 a year and he does uh
research and analytics for one of the
big mutual fund companies and he does it
from his office in his home and has for
10 years before work from homeless
school he was doing work from home and
he has lived uh in ski resort areas he
has lived in um uh Nashville now uh and
so forth and so I you know I think you
can do your job and the job of analytics
from almost anywhere and I don't think
they require you to be in the city
physically anymore
yeah I that's definitely the case
for us like during college we were
totally work from home now I got in the
office like
30 days a week
um so yeah but I'm saying there might be
the competitors or there might be people
in a specific Fields using your same
skills a certain industry that you
research and you become known for that
industry for one of the mutual fund
companies or something like that that
you can do totally work from home my
buddy did it before work from home was a
thing
yeah and you think in most cases it's
probably worth it at this I mean
especially if I start it's what you want
where do you want to live I mean you're
a single guy I take it you live in New
York City it's very cool and very fun to
live in New York City in a lot of ways I
love visiting there I personally it
wouldn't be the quality of life I want
to live there but I do enjoy the city I
used to enjoy it a lot more than I do
now
kind of screwed up up there right now
but the uh but it's a great town it's
got a great Vibe I love the energy I
love New Yorkers people that have lived
there their whole lives and stuff I just
I always relate to them because they're
high energy they're butt kickers they
get it done I like the environment I
like the culture of it but I still
wouldn't want to live in the city I got
enough country boy in me I want some
green grass
yeah so it's interesting you mentioned
that because I'm originally from from uh
from upstate New York but after 11 year
the past like two years I've come to
like the area you know I have a lot of
family and friends connections here yeah
so well there's nothing there's nothing
wrong with staying there you're not
doing anything morally wrong you're not
being irresponsible you make enough
money to live there but it's going to
cost you more to live there so you're
not going to prosper mathematically as
much as if you made 150 somewhere else
so it's okay to move there's nothing but
but if you're wanting us to tell you to
move we're not going to tell you to move
now if you told me you made sixty
thousand dollars a year and you couldn't
make ends meet on Manhattan I would say
that's true you're probably not living
in Manhattan making 60k is probably not
happening uh I mean you might for a
little while but it's that's a tough one
yeah and with his career field he has a
great chance of that income continuing
to increase so I mean if you love New
York if that's somewhere where you want
to stay and you see
um your salary continue to go up then I
think eventually you'll have more margin
to save yeah what I would do is say
where do I want to build my life today
and by the way it's not doesn't have to
be permanent uh where do I want to build
my life tomorrow in the next season of
my life I mean you might say hey I want
to stay here and you might marry a lady
and you both decide to stay there or you
might go hey we're going to move and
raise kids in a different environment
you could do that any of those things
will work any of those things will be
fine so it's just a matter of what you
guys wanted what you want to do and
later if there's a you guys what you
guys want to do later but um
you know you should make those choices
based on uh lifestyle as long as the
math will work and in your case you've
got the option because the math works
yeah it's exactly would this would be a
totally different conversation like Dave
said if you made sixty thousand dollars
a year because that would be a true
challenge but thankfully you have the
margin right now I do not think to be in
your field you have to stay there though
I think with your company you might have
to stay there but I don't think you have
to stay there to be in your field so I
would check that part out if you want to
move that puts us out of the Ramsey Show
in the books thanks to Austin Ben Zach
Andrew and James in the booth the booth
dudes they make this thing happen this
is the Ramsay show we'll be back with
you before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
foreign
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three-minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsesolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]